quoi de mieux que le salon du made in
france à paris pour mettre en avant
l'artisanat des yvelines originaire de
plaisir sandrine delhumeau expose ses
créations des écharpes en soie sous la
bannière de l'association la révolution
du fait main une fabrication manuelle et
artisanale est essentielle pour libye
noise il ya l'importance du geste
la maîtrise d'un geste ou la qualité du
travail si la précision modélistes de
formation voilà cinq ans qu'elle produit
des écharpes
une activité qu'elle a débuté par hasard
lorsqu'elle occupé son premier poste
dans une tissuthèque il y avait des
échantillons de soie imprimée qui ne
servaient la personne qui allait partir
à la poubelle
donc j'ai dit non moi je ne peux pas
laisser partir ça à la poubelle donc je
les ai récupérées et j'ai créé ma
première écharpe
de fil en aiguille elle fabrique
différentes écharpes en soie circulaire
soit classique et même des foulards
plusieurs styles de soit utilisé des
satins des crêpes de chine des twin ou
encore des mousselines mon intérêt c'est
de mélanger les différentes soit pour
avoir des effets différents
et pour ne pas avoir un aspect trop
lourd autour du cou donc c'est pour ça
que j'aime bien mélanger les différentes
matières
et c'est dans ce type de salon qu'elle
peut partager sa passion et donner de
précieux conseils
selon la manière dont vous allez place
et les chars autour du cou
couleur on se plaçait différemment il a
par exemple de la m comme ceux ci l'a
retourné dans l'autre sens il faire à
chaque fois une écharpe différentes
je trouve ça très intéressant le choix
des matières et l'assemblage et la voilà
les couleurs la matière et les
explications qui ont été données par la
suite mais voilà c'est l'originalité et
les voilà le fait d'avoir un article
unique que ce soit au salon ou dans son
atelier sandrine passe du temps à poser
sa griffe
elle vient de finir une écharpe
circulaire un temps de fabrication de
près d'une heure petit retour en arrière
sur découvrir ses secrets
je commence donc comme je disais à
brasser les soirs c'est à dire à les
mélanger à trouver quel imprimés va
correspondre un autre
quelle harmonie de couleurs je vais
créer je vais maintenant les assemblées
à la machine pour démarrer mon panneau
en fait alors la couture anglais c'est
une couture double qui permet de
complètement emprisonner les bords du
tissu en fallait cacher les bords du
tissu pour éviter les effilochage et
rendre un résultat plus beaucoup plus
nets et mieux fini après chaque couture
jeu j'écrase d'abord ma culture d'abord
je coupe le bord du tissu
je repasse une première fois puis une
seconde fois et là maintenant je vais
refaire une deuxième piqûre autour de
cette première pour complètement fermée
six aux machines à coudre fer à repasser
sandrine répète ce mouvement jusqu à
finaliser son écharpe en période de
création elle passe entre huit et dix
heures par jour trois à quatre fois par
semaine dans son atelier à travailler
mais c'est avant tout une passion et un
plaisir de soi